the undertaker never backs down
scooby-doo original movie starring the
WWE Superstars I think it'd still be
superstars we are acting all the time
we are literally doing that we go out
there with a little bit of persona you
know different persona and the ring than
we are in real life and I think you know
it's it's why the transition for people
like the rock and Cena and Batista has
been you know has been kind of like I
wouldn't say easy but like not not too
difficult you know what I mean kind of
like seamless but now I'm having a great
time like you know you never do
different projects like this it just
kind of breaks it up a little bit you
know it's a lot of fun to do and it's
great experience for me especially being
like part of this for this franchise
which I watched as a kid myself big fan
of Scooby and Scrappy and Shaggy so now
it's great I love being involved in
these things and I obviously would love
to do more more TV more voiceover stuff
and more movies I'm actually teaming up
with the Miz which I'm always seemed to
be with the Miz and stuff like you know
tough enough and then we did send this a
little over together so then no now
we're collaborating and one of the best
movies the whole time and something I
definitely grew up watching so I'm very
excited about it
what was the kind of doing the
voice-over work process where I was that
easy tough no it was really hard to be
honest like obviously I did the the
movies and stuff like that where you can
stand in front of the person and feed
off each other
but doing it animated ways and just in
in a microphone by yourself and a small
booth is probably awkward and it
exhausting actually was surprisingly
exhausting but it's great I loved it
what do you get you're making us look
dead ridiculous well I actually did this
one before I did I did voiceover turtles
this was a great help to me as well and
just kind of like gave me that
experience about to never never had
before but my work to carry out any
Williams who's also played bebop in
Turtles movie and I weave about in the
you know
we're about the same in the same
Paramount's studio doing voiceover stuff
and were able to bounce off each other
are there none awful lot from him you
know with the wrestlers being involved
in in one of these well action-packed
movie like scooby-doo there's definitely
gonna be some kind of physical activity
so at the end of the movie let's just do
blonde spoilers is the ghost's face
removed and is it you maybe that's the
way I see what the way to say okay you
have to remove my face to be it goes I'm
very pale well thank you very much
you're not ghostly make sure to
scooby-doo and curse this bay demon
you